and you write about forgiving yourself
in a way that I also thought was very
powerful
um you seem to have a bit of a I I don't
think this is you know like out of turn
given given the book but you seem to
have a bit of a chip on your shoulder or
um uh in part because you grew up one of
the uh lone immigrant families uh in
South Carolina in a context where uh you
were very acutely aware of your identity
and this is something I also can relate
to Growing Up in Upstate New York in the
70s as one of the lone Asian families uh
you know like I had a lot of uh teasing
and
um some fights you know kid kids are
generally uh pretty quick to point out
differences uh with other kids and you
write about having to forgive yourself
and then also forgiving others uh and
having that actually as something that
helped fuel your ability to to make
positive things happen in the world
nearly enough I mean for me I absolutely
had a chip on my shoulder I grew up in a
place where people would come up to my
parents adults not even kids you'd go
back to where you came from and in my
mind I would think New York because I'm
from New York
um I grew up in Queens and I just
remember thinking how could people
actually say that to someone else that
they don't even know and yet you know I
spent my whole childhood being othered
being that person who ate strange food
and you know didn't quite fit in and was
always you know no matter where I went
people would just ask questions about
you know that felt really intrusive and
and I really struggled with the bullying
and all of those things and yet I
realized that for me I just protected
myself right I built a hard shell I if I
was just really quiet and I had a hard
shell and nobody could get could
penetrate then I would win and I
realized that when you become when you
know when you kind of protect yourself
by building this wall it becomes
impenetrable for you to exit either also
and so I had to really work through that
and Cheryl Sandberg actually called me
out on this I was at a meeting and I
said something in front of the other
Executives and she said
afterwards she pulled me aside she said
you can stop fighting now you've won
and she realized it wasn't about
fighting for your rights it was actually
I was just fighting everyone and she's
like wow you're feeding everyone around
you you need to back off and it took me
a long time to understand what she was
saying but it was so transformative to
me because that fight was everything I
had and I had to find a new identity
well what am I fighting for now and so I
had to really find a lot of Grace in
that and and I have over the years that
at the time that kind of that that power
of like being angry and upset at how I
grew up was rocket fuel because it drove
me to succeed to be ambitious to do all
the things
and then suddenly it was starting to
burn me up and it was starting to hurt
my relationships and I had to really
retool and figure out where I wanted to
go from there I'll share with you when I
was younger I used to braid myself for a
mistake oftentimes a mistake that only I
would notice like mistakes that other
people didn't didn't even see uh and
being able to let that sort of thing go
became necessary for me to be able to uh
put myself out there or do certain
things because you're going to screw up
um all the time in that context and if
you're an introvert I think a lot of
introverts are naturally kind of hard on
themselves that way
so I could relate very much to this
lesson because I when someone asked me a
while ago it's like hey how are you uh
how did you have to evolve to put
yourself out in public life and I said I
just had to stop being so hard on myself
that is absolutely true I think so often
we're the hardest on ourselves more than
anybody else I remember when you know I
was growing up I was the one who said I
got a 99 what happened to the last point
I was my parents your parents dab come
on
they're actually way more laid back than
you would expect
Billy why do you study so hard but I've
had this internal drive to I was when I
was in third grade I'm like I'm going to
graduate first in my class so I can get
a scholarship to college what third
grader actually sits there in plots that
but for me it was my only escape from
something I really really struggled with
this is rural South Carolina right yeah
it was a small town in South Carolina
it's about 45 minutes outside of
Charleston and you know I just really
struggled with what it was like to grow
up being different I said I'm going to
go to a place where I'm accepted but in
order to get there I had to get to
College my parents could only help me so
much so I'm like I'm gonna graduate
number one I'm gonna go to college I'm
going to get a scholarship and I'm never
going to come back here and so much of
that is that that Rocket Fuel I talked
about right that drive to like break
through every barrier and that helps me
until it no longer helps me so I was a
perfectionist and an introvert which is
you know maybe two things that are too
much compatible in some ways and so I
had to really let go of that because in
parenting in particular there is no
perfect and they'll let you know when
you're not perfect
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you